[Music]
I don't believe it
how could this happen to me BTS
they unfollowed me why she's even still
here just
three night they can feel my leg and my
arm
they used to follow me the bottommost
whatapp that was wrong lost what
happened what did I do wrong what did I
do
why did you follow me at the first place
if you're just going to follow me
what that
[Music]
I'm gonna have to read the reddit rose
to feel better about myself this is the
lowest point of my [ __ ] life this is
the it doesn't get worse okay let's do
this
I am the perfect man there's nothing to
roast about but let's just see it anyway
to see what you guys said
what kind of mean things you guys said
okay well here here first of all I
apparently did it wrong you're not
supposed to use the phones and tablets
okay here's the first one fourteen
thousand points
judging from the quality of this thread
I think you're going to struggle to make
his 50 and 10 you don't know how long
this video is going to be he's going to
read no I'm not and repeat at different
volumes and levels of cod oh you think
you know everything do you you think you
know everything that's great he has a
soundboard for oh shut up if he reads
this comment chain in the video he will
do exactly what we are describing by
exaggerate and an attempt to mock us oh
you think you know everything huh that
place we're not sure it bends providing
content or haters trying to actually
roast good job good job you know what I
appreciate the 10 minutes how long are
we how long are we into this
let's give him someone to speak about
hey pits try making a video on how you
felt when Wall Street Journal and Disney
made you cry on camera to 12 year olds
for their support well I guess that
means you're 12 because you watched it
huh can't argue with thanks straight-up
disproven your point
[ __ ] Gotham hill-hill doing Hill
doing like every other video well I
can't [ __ ] understand you so roast
declined Gotham
I missed I missed 26 PewDiePie when you
didn't have a youtube channel well
joke's on you [ __ ]
cuz I did and it was called youtube.com
/ pew dang disproven 2016 disproven
can't argue with facts
[ __ ] you leave this guy leave the guy
alone
it must be hard when everytime you go to
someone else's house you expect to see
Chris hands and asking you to take a
seat and question why you spend all day
talking to kids on YouTube only kids
watch shut up anyway I don't care
whatever listen you guys don't
understand BTS unfollowed me on Twitter
like words can't hurt me anymore
I am already broken and I can't be fixed
six and stones
BTS on Paulo's
ruined its route ruined your channel
peaked when you didn't have pace cam oh
yeah well joke's on you cuz [ __ ] you
there you go you're welcome week week
this roads our week roasts more like hey
yeah did someone turn up the AC a little
bit yeah laugh at my own ones shut up
you look like the only man in the world
who actually managed to grow his
virginity back and that's assuming it's
somehow lost that in the first place by
the way none of your concern but I put
my penis in many places that you don't
have to worry you don't have to worry
about it okay as you get older and your
face settles into adult looks you're
going from cute young Swede to lurch
from The Addams Family at an incredible
rate wait who's lurch and I don't know
who lurch is I see it I 100% see it what
you ruined more 12 year olds than the
Catholic Church hey man that's low for
the Catholic Church man come on let him
alone the creativity for the roads in
this comment section is on par with the
creativity on your channel yes your
content reminds me of Ikea simple
cheaply made and put together quickly
with no real effort
ah and that's good that won't skin I'll
give you that one
you know what I love IKEA and I'll take
it you know what I'll take it it's it's
surprisingly accurate as well to be fair
it can't be easy to think of fresh
content this many years into the game
that's [ __ ] right I want to see you
try tuna upload daily videos every
single goddamn day okay yeah I think
I've done a lot of great videos of
course some of them aren't gonna be
top-notch
but at least I [ __ ] try I try at
least okay I [ __ ] try I try my best
what am I supposed to do if I don't
upload videos daily people will be like
he's lazy now but if I don't if I upload
videos daily people are like he's
running out of ideas I can't win no
matter what I do there's no win except
if I do the videos ten minutes cuz the
ads the ads always win why we still here
just to supper every night I feel my leg
I'm not giving you free content you lazy
[ __ ] well you just did
thank you thank you thank you thank you
appreciate thank you I like I like this
one low budget filthy Frank okay yeah
yeah hard a million times higher but yet
still worst ever since do you bleach
your hair you look like a lesbian well I
mean I guess that's true hey it's a
bleach joke everyone it's a it's a
drinking bleach joke everyone high
chopper them on into your ladies drink
bleach and kill yourself man
the humor of Amy Schumer with the
personality of Cameron Diaz
thank you guys thank you appreciate it
all right well it looks like that's
that's the roast good job everyone
thank you reddit for roasting me
appreciate you taking the time Phil bill
honored Phil honored to be slightly
heated up I think is more like the term
BTS unfollowed me and nothing else is
ever going to hurt that much it's not
your fault reddit its BTS okay you gave
it your best shot
but nothing will ever hurt as much as
BTS unfollowing me on Twitter why are am
I still here god [ __ ] damn it
what did I do wrong I make a video
praising them saying I love them I want
to be them I want to marry them to here
but apparently not good enough just it's
the video ten minutes yet
[Music]